hey guys it's Justine and today oh my
goodness
we're playing Animal Crossing a lot of
you guys said you wanted me to play some
gameplay of this and a lot of you asked
what have I been doing in lockdown and
in quarantine and this is what I have
been doing I've been playing this game a
lot although my island doesn't really
look like I've been playing it a lot
like I feel like it should be a little
bit better than it is but I definitely
wanted to avoid okay that's kind of
boring for flavor I'll take it I will
take every single thing that I can get
but I've been playing this game a lot
I'll show you my house this is just
gonna be a little island tour show you
guys around give you a little look-see
of what I've been doing it's like I
don't even know it's actually pretty
terrible I just have a lot of stuff
before it was even worse I had so much
stuff everywhere that I couldn't
actually walk I'd have a mixer on the
floor Jenna gave me this really cool
radio today I don't have any songs no I
need to download some some songs from
keiki slider I should probably go to my
nook shop so I've got like a little fish
tank over here this little puffer fish
and what a hamster it's just hanging out
I don't think I have to feed him it he's
running on this wheel for like four or
five days solid incense and candles it's
my Zen zone this is my little area where
I sit here I sometimes like to leave my
island open so people can come and visit
so I sit here and they know that I'm
busy I'm not sure how they know that I'm
busy they just kind of I guess probably
realized that cuz I'm not doing anything
but sitting here I just started a little
garden of some seeds and stuff that I
collect from other peoples islands gotta
growing well
cuz there's not much there I also have a
little swap meet which I got inspired by
Edie he has a little swap meet at his or
you can leave something and then take
something this is the beginnings of it I
also have to make a custom sign but I
haven't really figured out how to do
that yet I'm gonna figured it out I have
to figure out how to make it not look
like crap
so I'm gonna do that later I also have
to replant all of these trees because I
planted them too close to the edge and
they haven't been growing so that's on
the to-do list for today I've just been
doing some fishing today I recorded this
already and I realized the audio wasn't
recording as I haven't done this in so
long and I had never gone into the
nausea
I've been playing this for weeks and I
actually let me see how long we're
playing it for eight days eight days
since lockdown eight days since my
birthday and I've been playing this a
lot but I had never gone into the museum
I would just go in give blathers my
nonsense and then say see you later I'm
out of here
the museum is really crazy the fact that
they built this in one day I don't think
I have any fossils I don't think I have
anything that you're gonna want to
donate yeah I didn't think so
this was my my favorite part about it
over here like the bugs and insects it's
so beautiful what is this how did you
make this in a day blathers look at this
big old tree I think this is incredible
you built this in a day you're a liar
yeah I don't know I don't understand I
remember playing this game before and
not wanting to give anything to the
museum because I'm like this is my stuff
back up don't touch cool great chat
blathers we're gonna go and see the rest
of my islands I showed you my house I
showed you sort of the layouts so this
is what my map looks like if I've got
five Islanders now this is my little
beach area this is a money tree which is
growing it can't wait for that I'm gonna
get this snail I still haven't got it
ran Juliet wouldn't know what to do I'm
gonna do something over here and I don't
remember this is the problem because I
get to the side track get in there go in
oh this is what I wanted I wanted a cake
cake beside our song I was gonna be in
the mails I'm not gonna have it now
gotta get used to not having things
immediately like groceries it's so weird
because in Los Angeles like grocery
delivery is something that I've been
doing for probably like eight years and
the fact now it's you can't even do it
because everybody is doing it so this is
what I've been studying those wait hang
on come here you little hopper this is
da Chico a rice grasshopper I don't
think I've caught like this before
it's blue easy because I'm
I'm lazy here I love the layout of these
houses a lot I kinda wanted to have
everybody close together so that I could
just go chat with them like quickly this
guy was sick the other day he I went
into his house he coughed and sneezed
all over me oh my gosh when my villagers
has grown up I'm terrified he needs
tissues oh gosh
yeah you do need some medicine but
there's no cure yet body you disgusting
hog haven't you no it's not you
you're new you just moved in it was
Jacob social distancing told you
understand the spread of corona I think
this is his house he's in here I'm gonna
yell at him I hope not Jacobs house hey
how are you with the latest
I like that pink vacuum though maybe
she'll gift me one a real kind gesture
these houses were so annoying to make
because you had to piece together all of
the different pieces here to find a
furniture get to get all of this stuff
together I mean it really wasn't that
big of a deal I mean like what else do I
have to do there's my garden or a lawn
gnome there really have to replant those
trees but I'm just like thinking about
all this time that I'm wasting and
they're not
if you having lots of friends visit I'll
sometimes just leave this on and then
I'm surprised with visitors all day long
it's superb oh it's online I have to do
a visiting my episode here for you guys
are enjoying this oh this is you I don't
have together of a couple of this does
anybody remember when I made my Island
on the southern hemisphere it's actually
a good thing that I did because all of
my friends on the northern hemisphere
like we all have different types of
things and that our seasons will be
different so we'll all be able to have
different things this is him this is the
Corolla Kaufer I was wearing that themed
outfit that he was wearing yesterday I'm
gonna pick this flower somebody was a
plan of those because I don't have those
here I mean a lot of people that have
never played this game they follow me on
Twitter it's hard to really explain it
to somebody if you've never played it
sure some of you guys haven't played
this either - you're like what the heck
is even happening right now huh yeah I
didn't think that you had that he talks
so much please do not tell me but I
accidentally click please tell me
hitting that fast-forward button as fast
as I can
Mabel has didn't buy these shoes those
are really nice don't like it I'm
sticking with this Timmy and Tommy I've
been enjoying the reddit threads of
people jailing them to use her ransom
you guys have any other animal crossing
tips I would love to hear them because I
feel like there's so much stuff even
though this seems like such a simple
game it's really not I mean if you've
played it you guys know but if you
haven't played it you're like well
you're just doing stuff I'm doing stuff
but there's a lot to what I'm doing
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this gameplay and want to see more leave
me a comment and maybe I'll do it again
I'm really excited though I've set up
this setup today I just posted a video
talking about my perfect gaming setup
and then guess what I ripped it all down
and I started over classic classic
Justin I'll see you guys in my next
video
[Music]